[Music]  [Applause]  the gathers you seem think I have a step  left use already in the elbow bump in  the lane dump it's a parter I thought  they're going to let it go cut on the  drive  there's the slap on the are I'm able to  take the contact that's still finish  bacon strip didn't work that time she  almost knocked it out landed in high  gear his drive she just kind of no  hesitation and then all sudden Veronica  almost backs up he knew  [Applause]  so here's what took his watch his eyes  they've never lived where he's gonna go  and right here he's scenes where he's  gonna go go Beasley's got it  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  Julia Mike Porter Jr on fire